knock knock who's there exploring cloud
identity exploring cloud identity who
learn how to unify access to products
and services with cloud identity in this
new series who's there exploring cloud
identity most businesses depend on a
diverse array of technologies to operate
day to day your clients need a way to
interface with products like viewing
products via a website or an app
employees need to access company
services on their laptops tablets and
phones companies need to manage
on-boarding and off-boarding employees
in directories and the business may
depend on third-party services like
customer management systems and
messaging applications some of these
services may exist on premises but other
services are most useful when they are
accessible outside of the office
personally I both love and loathe that I
can check my work email and my devices
from any location so how can a business
effectively maintain secure access to
all these technologies well one great
solution to this tangle of technologies
is Google cloud identity cloud identity
is a unified solution for your
business's identity needs it protects
company data using the beyond Corp
security model and Google's threat
intelligence signals and it enables
people to access thousands of apps with
single sign-on and minge their company
accounts using the same process as their
personal Google accounts cloud identity
helps your company transition to the
cloud by integrating with your existing
systems on a reliable trusted platform
so to boil it all down cloud identity is
a suite of products that help your
company unify management of people apps
and devices now if I went in depth on
everything that cloud identity does that
would be a very long video so rather
than trying to squeeze all this
information into a single video I've
decided to make this series who's there
exploring cloud identity I'll be talking
about four main facets to cloud identity
managing users devices
directories and apps we will explore
each facet of cloud identity in depth
starting with managing a path indication
and authorization through cloud identity
platform sounds great I'm excited to
learn more about cloud identity and what
can do for my company but I still didn't
get the joke you should probably just -
fair enough but but what about this one
why did the program or use BIM because I
couldn't figure out how to exit No Hey
exiting BIM
[Music]
you
[Music]